[Musique]
bienvenue dans le débat sur France 24
26e jour de guerre en Ukraine les Russes
bombardent de plus en plus intensément
des villes comme Mario Paul l'Ukraine ne
peut accepter aucun
ultimatum de la Russie a dit le
président zélinski à Kiev un centre
commercial a été bombardé le bilan et
d'au moins 8 morts la capitale est à
nouveau sous couvre-feu à partir de ce
soir la semaine dernière les russes
auraient pulvérisé un entrepôt
d'armement dans la région des Carpates
ukrainiennes à l'aide d'un missile
hypersonique les Russes recherchent
également des supplétifs de l'armée
notamment en Syrie alors bombardement
intensif envoient d'amicilli-personique
appelle à des supplétifs Vladimir
Poutine est-il dans une fuite en avant
quel est le rapport de force sur le
terrain ou en sont les discussions à
diplomatiques on va en parler avec nos
invités mais on va tout de suite en
Ukraine à mikolaif retrouvez notre
envoyé spécial Julie dungelhof Julie
bonsoir vous êtes à nicolaïve c'est une
ville assiégée depuis des jours comme
Mario Paul d'ailleurs racontez-nous
plus précise j'ai passé la journée à
Mika live et je suis rentré à Odessa ce
soir toute la journée mikolave a été
sous les feux russe des bombardements
aériens intensifs avec plusieurs lieux
qui ont été touchés nous avons pu nous
rendre devant l'un d'entre eux notamment
un hôtel qui avait été bombardé par et
bien des tirs aériens et l'hôtel avait
été quasiment totalement endommagé les
bâtiments à côté également par chance il
y avait personne dans cet endroit seul
le gardien de l'immeuble a été
légèrement blessé mais tous les
alentours et bien été couverts de débris
et puis il y a eu un hôpital
psychiatrique également qui a été touché
à mikolaïve aujourd'hui ainsi que
d'autres lieux dans la banlieue de la
ville selon plusieurs témoins avec
lesquels j'ai pu parler et bien ils
avaient la sensation que c'est
bombardements c'était intensifié
aujourd'hui je vous le rappelle un
vendredi et bien Nicolas il a été
largement touché puisque une caserne
militaire a été sous le feu russe
également et qu'au moins 50 soldats
auraient été tués
de recherche à l'IRIS nous allons avoir
avec nous en duplex de Londres Anastasia
Kiril & Co et puis nous attendons à
guérir Poncet qui est un peu de retard
journaliste défense du point et nous
allons tout de suite et bien à le vivre
à le vivre vous savez cette ville à
l'ouest de l'Ukraine retrouver Gulliver
crack l'un de nos envoyer spéciaux à la
correspondant d'ailleurs dans la région
bonsoir Gulliver on peut dire que la
stratégie russe en écoutant d'ailleurs
Julie dungelhoff il y a un instant c'est
de poursuivre le siège des villes et de
bombarder de plus en plus intensément
oui ça semble être la stratégie employée
sur mikolaev sur Mario Paul peut-être
que s'étire sur des ça qui selon les
militaires ukrainiens ont été tirés
depuis la mer sur le début d'une
stratégie similaire au dessin mais je
pense que les forces terrestres sont
loin de ça et aussi à Nicolas ce n'est
pas exactement le même cas de figure que
Mario Paul puisqu'il est encore
relativement facile d'entrer et de
sortir dans la ville même si ce n'est
pas complètement sans danger c'est un
peu la même histoire pour tchernie Give
au nord de Kiev qui est partiellement
assiégé mais il est tout de même
possible dit d'y arriver et d'en sortir
et le bombardement continue sur ces
villes d'une manière moins intense je
pense que sur Mario Paul mais tout de
même et puis il ne peut pas oublier des
endroits comme cvodonet que Louis dont
le nord de l'aublastes de loin ce que le
gouverneur de la région de luansque
disait aujourd'hui que les bombardements
sur cette région du nord de la région de
Luans
qui était contrôlé par l'Ukraine pendant
les 8 ans de guerre depuis 2014 et très
intensement bombardé pour Kiev ce n'est
pas encore là cette situation il y a de
temps en temps des des bâtiments qui
sont touchés mais ce n'est pas le
bombardement intense qu'on voit sur
d'autres villes pour le moment du mois
merci Gulliver crack donc en direct de
le vivre générale Dominique de l'or
Mario Paul mikolaï finalement est-ce que
ce sont de nouvelles aleps est-ce que
les Russes maintenant visent
volontairement les habitations les
écoles les hôpitaux est-ce qu'on est
dans une escalade verticale une sorte de
fuite en avant alors on dit au 21e
siècle que la ville est l'ultime champ
de bataille c'est-à-dire que la ville
présente des caractères
particulièrement intéressants dès lors
qu'on a un faible infort pourquoi parce
que la ville est un pouvoir égalisateur
au sens que les combats entre disons le
faible qui va défendre la ville et le
fort qui arrive avec une armée blindée
et bien ils vont se retrouver à peu près
au même niveau ça c'est le premier
élément le deuxième élément c'est que il
faut être 6 fois plus nombreux pour
pouvoir prendre une ville ce qui veut
dire que dans les exemples que vous
citez que les Russes sont pas encore en
position de prendre toutes les villes
Nico live au dessin Mario Paul c'est
presque fait mais en tout cas Kiev par
exemple donc ça veut dire qu'il y a
beaucoup de résistance encore du côté
ukrainien au plan stratégique c'est une
question de volonté c'est à dire que le
pouvoir politique de celui qui défend
décide de livrer bataille dans ces
villes là alors ça des avantages comme
je viens de dire au plan militaire ça
aussi les normes inconvénient parce que
la population civile est mêlée à ses
combats là et qu'elle va souffrir elle
va souffrir ou elle doit devoir partir
c'est donc ce que vous faisiez allusion
Alep on peut faire aussi allusion à
Mossoul où il a fallu neuf mois au trop
irakienne et départ la coalition
internationale pour pour s'emparer de la
ville et on peut faire en parallèle
aujourd'hui on peut faire un parallèle
c'est-à-dire que un siège ça ça peut
durer longtemps
et il faut beaucoup de moyens alors
est-ce que les Russes sont capables et
veulent le faire c'est une autre chose
est-ce que les autorités politiques
ukrainiennes veulent transformer leur
principal ville en grand champ de
bataille pour montrer leur détermination
peut-être peut-être mais là on voit bien
qu'on a à la fois une réflexion
stratégique pour les hommes politiques
et puis au niveau tactique pour les
chefs militaires qui se retrouvent dans
des configurations très particulières
qui elles combat en ville on va écouter
vous le dire le président
ukrainien
les Russes nous ont posé cette ultimatum
en nous disant voici les conditions à
remplir et alors nous mettrons fin à la
guerre non ce n'est pas la façon de
procéder et cela ne dépend pas que de
moi
Bretagne toute la question est que le
pouvoir et le peuple ont la même vision
des choses nous ne pouvons pas appliquer
un ultimatum
mais moi comment cela est-il possible ce
n'est pas faisable vous auriez à tous
nous détruire alors seulement
l'ultimatum pourrait être appliqué
et dates
ils disent donnez-nous vos villes Kiev
Mario Paul raquive mais ni les habitants
ni le président ne pourrait le faire
maintenant
on le voit dans les villes qui sont
occupées lorsque les soldats russes les
pénètrent les gens ne se rendent pas
le drapeau ukrainien alors qu'est-ce que
vous voulez faire voulez vous simplement
nous détruire tous et bien la seule
chose que je peux dire c'est que oui
l'ultimatum ne pourra être mise en œuvre
que lorsqu'il n'y aura plus personne
on voit toujours la même détermination
du côté de Zelinski du côté des
Ukrainiens on en parlait il y a un
moment est-ce qu'il peut y avoir des
négociations l'Ukraine a vraiment rejeté
l'ultimatum de Moscou qui exagère
exigeait la capitulation de Mario Paul
oui je pense que la négociation elle a
déjà commencé elle en est assez tout
préliminaire c'est à dire les Russes ont
posé un certain nombre d'exigences qui
sont effectivement sont considérés comme
des ultimatums à juste titre d'ailleurs
j'imagine par Monsieur zen
les points principaux c'est
neutralisation c'est
légitimations de l'État indépendant de
des deux états de deniètz kelloggansk
légitimation de l'annexion de la Crimée
et armement enfin désarmement en fait ou
armement minimal de l'Ukraine face à la
Russie alors après il y a aussi Mario
Paul et d'autres éléments qui sont un
peu secondaires ce à quoi d'ailleurs
zelens ajouter et garantie
internationale sur la neutralité parce
que il s'est fait il s'est fait doucher
si je tire en 94 et en 97 quand on lui a
garanti sa neutralité c'était la Russie
qui la garantissait donc là les
Ukrainiens il faut qu'ils jouent serré
pour avoir une une garantie solide on en
est au début de la négociation
on parle de neutralité à l'Autrichienne
d'une neutralité à la Suisse d'une
traité qu'est-ce que ça veut dire
neutralité
suédoise ni de la neutralité
autrichienne et qui voulait une
neutralité à l'Ukrainienne ce qui est
pas idiot et ce qui est même neutralité
à l'Ukrainienne
on devine on devine quand même c'est à
dire que l'Autriche un traité avec la
Russie avec quelques raisons de penser
que la Russie ne tomberait pas dessus la
Russie soviétique la même chose pour la
Suède qui a une armée forte donc en fait
la neutralité à l'Ukrainienne ça veut
dire des garanties internationales
militaires de la part des États-Unis de
l'OTAN et d'autres pays très solides
face à la Russie beaucoup plus solide
que non non les Suédois les finlandais
ou les Autrichiens Anastasia Hélène que
vous nous avez rejoint un journaliste
indépendantes de coralisatrice du
documentaire Poutine la mafia et la
Russie bienvenue à vous vous êtes avec
nous en directe en duplex en direct de
Londres est-ce que Poutine Poutine on
voit n'est plus sûr de remporter une
victoire militaire est-ce que son
discours de propagande n'en n'est-il pas
d'autant plus emphatique est-ce qu'il a
besoin d'une victoire pour l'afficher
auprès des Russes
justement à regarder le discours de
propagande de de Vladimir Poutine ça n'a
pas l'air du tout que les négociations
commencent ou bien un apaisement
commence donc monsieur glinyasty
atténue on peut les propos de la
propagande officier mais toujours est-il
qu'il parle de nazification de l'Ukraine
et même
les médias d'État publient des articles
dans le sens que les Russie l'Ukraine
c'est le même peuple donc
malheureusement il s'agit selon
plusieurs analystes militaires de la
part de la Russie de prétendre par
exemple de prétendre d'ouvrir des
couloirs humanitaires d'apaiser un peu
mais pour gagner du temps et pour
ce enfin recruter un peu encore plus
d'hommes dans l'armée russe donc je vois
pas de cette apaisement si vous voulez
quand vous parlez de recruter justement
d'hommes dans l'armée russe de quelle
manière ça se passe on sait que il y a
maintenant à lentement de mercenaires de
mercenaires en l'occurrence en Syrie on
parle également d'une coopération avec
les biélorus mais j'ai vu que les
troupes biélorusse finalement n'était
très très faible à accompagner l'armée
russe est-ce que vous savez où on en est
justement des recrutements à la fois des
Biélorusses mais également des
paramilitaires de la force Wagner
oui un Wagner pour l'instant elle est en
dehors de cette aventure parce que
Wagner était très occupé en Afrique il
est toujours et le plan initial de
Poutine c'était de gagner l'Ukraine en
trois jours c'était pas prévu par contre
on propose maintenant de contrats aux
Russes donc des contrats comme pas les
appeler parce que les appeler c'est donc
on les a piégés qu'ils étaient utilisés
à agneukraine mais après cette pratique
est visiblement a été
condamnée mais maintenant on propose des
contrats
qu'est-ce que ça va donner il faut voir
dans les prochains jours mais en gros
tous ceux qui ont une petite expérience
militaire maintenant sont approchés pour
aller à combattre en Ukraine il y a des
tarifs qui sont proposés 54 dollars un
par jour il y a des procédures
simplifiées par exemple avant ça prenait
un mois et demi pour prendre un nouveau
contractuel dans l'armée maintenant
ça sera possible presque les médias donc
il y a des bureaux de l'armée en locaux
des commissariats comme les appels en
russe qui s'occupe de tout ça et c'est
assez en même temps il y a des cercueils
qui commencent à arriver en Russie et
malgré le patriotisme il y a quand même
aussi des parfois des citoyens déçus
est-ce que vous pourriez rebondir
là-dessus justement général de Mick de
l'or d'abord quand on appelle des
réservices en renfort est-ce que ça veut
dire qu'ils sont plutôt moins bien
formés est-ce que c'est le signe aussi
d'une démotivation du côté des soldats
russes est-ce que finalement les
objectifs des Russes aujourd'hui sont
devenus illusoires
alors si vous voulez sur les premiers
points les réservistes vont d'abord
tenir des fonctions qui sont pas des
fonctions de première ligne il y a toute
unité de soutien qui vont aider les
forces qui sont engagées déjà assurer
leur soutien logistique etc et puis ils
vont former ils vont former des
fantassins parce qu'ils en ont ils en
manquaient donc ils vont former mais ça
va prendre quelques semaines pour aller
vite en allant très vite enfin ils vont
le faire alors démotivations
il est très difficile de jouer entre il
y a des propagandes des deux côtés il
faut quand même rester lucide
certainement des gens qui qui vont pas
de getter de cœur dans des combats en
ville d'une manière générale dans les
combats et un combat de ville en plus
car c'est aussi un des aspects que l'on
peut assister c'est que le le combat en
ville crée beaucoup plus de stress
post-traumatique que n'importe quel
autre combat pourquoi parce que on tire
dans des dans des maisons on voit
parfois des civils tués même souvent et
puis on voit des objets qui rappellent
la conscience qu'on peut avoir de sa
propre famille donc c'est extrêmement
difficile donc on est obligé de relever
les troupes pour les maintenir à avec
suffisamment de combativité donc le
combat en ville très c'est pas du tout
souhaité et donc ça nécessite beaucoup
d'éléments si je contraint donc
actuellement je pense pas que les Russes
sera en mesure de mener plusieurs
chaînes sièges simultanément
actuellement Mario Paul fixe des forces
considérables russes qui ne peut pas
donc aller ailleurs par principe
lorsqu'elle le siège sera terminé pour
aller sur une autre direction verser par
exemple des redessa ce qui veut dire que
d'un point de vue stratégique l'action
menée par les combattants Ukrainiens à
marieupal ralentit le processus d'avancé
des forces russes et d'une certaine
manière sert évidemment la volonté
krainienne de se battre donc en même
temps sont obligés de rester également
sur leur position
jusqu'à la fin moi ce qui survivrons
c'est toujours à partir du moment où on
veut pas se rendre il y a pas 36
solutions et il se rendront dans le les
derniers se rendront peut-être et encore
c'est même pas sûr donc est-ce que ça
veut dire que les objectifs de Poutine
sont obligés de changer aujourd'hui
alors militaires je crois que l'agenda
est complètement changé
la campagne telle qu'il avait imaginé
sur la base d'un
d'une certaine
complaisante d'une partie de la
population
ukrainienne se trouve totalement déjoué
ce qui veut dire que là où il avait
pensé mettre 150 000 hommes en fait il
en faudrait 400000 ou 500 000 et les a
pas
vous êtes d'accord avec ça donc Poutine
change d'objectif aujourd'hui donc ça
veut dire quoi effectivement on parle de
recrutement de mercenaires pour
renforcer un petit peu parce que
peuple frères comme il le dit lui-même
en fait c'est vrai que les soldats
russes ils ont pas tellement envie
d'aller fouiller dans les maisons pour
tuer des combattants donc il est obligé
d'en prendre d'autres non il a
complètement changé ses plans et plus le
temps passe plus ces plans seront
brutaux en fait parce que effectivement
quand on n'a pas d'hommes aujourd'hui ce
qu'on a est-ce que c'est une fuite en
avant justement c'est-à-dire on va
utiliser l'hypersonique on va utiliser
des mercenaires syriens des tchétchène
c'est-à-dire qu'on fait c'est l'escalade
en fait c'est l'escalade oui mais ça
veut pas dire fut un avant c'est à dire
qu'en fait il veut prendre le maximum de
gages on est dans une phase toute toute
préliminaire de la négociation en gros
les buts de guerre des uns des autres ça
apparaît à peu près on voit pas très
bien parce qu'effectivement la pression
est très forte tueuse Ukrainiens donc on
il y a quand même un tout début de
négociation parce que au contraire
Antalya ils ont mis j'avais pas parlé de
la nazification en effet ça c'est
important c'est un point très spécifique
à l'Ukraine il faudra j'allais dire
tordre le coup à cette idée donc là
aussi c'est un élément de négociation
difficile la signification c'est un vrai
texte pour la Russie peut de mettre son
nez dans les affaires internes de
l'Ukraine donc ça l'Ukraine ne
l'acceptera pas donc on est vraiment
tout à fait au début mais ce qui est sûr
c'est que compte tenu de la déconvenue
initiale de des Russes de Poutine on est
dans un processus d'escalade c'est à
dire que c'est il pensait que les
soldats seraient accueillis avec des
roses ils sont accueillis avec des
cocktails Molotov il y a mobilisation
tout un peuple qui a création d'une
nation dans le sang et dans le feu c'est
clair et donc s'il veut prendre des
villes maintenant il faut les écraser de
bombe et manifestement au début c'était
pas son intention et avec Mario Paul on
voit que bah ça commence à devenir une
vraie guerre et non plus une guerre avec
tous les moyens une guerre totale et
à ce moment là entre les problématiques
de crime de guerre voilà la crème de
guerre ça veut dire terroriser la
population ça veut dire c'est ça en fait
ce que veut aujourd'hui Vladimir Poutine
ben je crois qu'il a pas le choix s'il
veut prendre Mario Paul c'est retirer
c'est inhérent à ce type de bataille
c'est à partir du moment où on mène la
bataille au milieu de la population il y
a forcément la population va devenir
va souffrir énormément c'est pas ça
qu'on appelle une fuite en avant alors
pas exactement au sens qu'il est obligé
de monter en puissance il laisse un
couloir pour évacuer un maximum de
population bon on peut on peut en parler
et puis il amène de l'artillerie de la
retirer et puis et puis il va s'engager
je pense que Mario Paul s'il l'a pas
pris à la fin de la semaine c'est qu'il
est vraiment des grandes difficultés
Anastasia kerylenco donc ça sera un test
Mario Paul est-ce qu'il a changé selon
vous qui connaissez bien qui avait
enquêté justement sur l'entourage de
Vladimir Poutine sur le Kremlin est-ce
qu'il a changé d'objectif Vladimir
Poutine dans cette guerre aujourd'hui
au début de cette guerre l'objectif
c'était de proclamer plusieurs publics
populaires indépendantes c'est clair par
exemple le manifeste de la proclamation
de ces République a été partagée par des
médias de propagande il y a quelques
jours il parlait juste d'une seule
République Populaire à Carson qui était
en train d'être proclamé soi-disant hier
vous avez mentionné les tchétchène il y
a le président tchétchène qui disait que
même à Mario Paul ils sont accueillis
avec des roses donc il a dit ça il y a
toujours il change pas
non mais c'est partager grosso modo
c'est partager par les médias d'État
russe les porte-paroles parce que les
médias et le véhiculent simplement le
message des officiers
néanmoins c'est clair que à Mario poil
il y a bon les choses ne se passent pas
comme prévu des analystes militaires de
Russie les bureaux c'est fiable donne
encore une semaine à Mario poule et
entre temps les médias d'État ils disent
que c'est les Ukrainiens qui commettent
un des crimes de guerre donc il continue
leurs efforts à discréditer
l'usukrainien et en fait c'est très
difficile de se voir est-ce que les
objectifs de Poutine change le monde du
Kremlin et maintenant très difficile à
peindre même si vous avez des fuites
vous êtes pas sûr que que c'est vrai il
y a une analyse qui se dit proche du
Kremlin qui dit que Poutine est malade
et ça fait depuis 10 ans qui est qui dit
ça donc
je me méfie consciencieusement des
informations de ce genre parce que il y
a des théories je dirais un peu de
complot que au sein du Facebook les
services spéciaux russes il y a pour la
quelqu'un qui veut faire tomber Poutine
etc mais il faut être très prudent avec
cette théories là les accueils les
corridors humanitaires pardon général de
Mick Delors alors justement est-ce qu'il
y aurait est-ce qu'il y a un accord
d'après donc les Russes là ont demandé
en fait c'est un ultimatum qu'ils ont
sur Mario Paul il y a une sorte de
corridor qui a été mis en place qui va
d'ailleurs vers les localités dominées
par les Russes donc là les Ukrainiens
disent qu'on force les enfants
d'ailleurs à y aller qu'on enlève les
passeports qu'on retire leur passeport
aux Ukrainiens qu'est-ce qui se passe
sur ces corridors
suffisamment puisque je crois que les
deux derniers journalistes ont quitté
Mario Paul dans la journée
et encore je crois que le dernier
c'était un nouveau correspondants qui
était venu à partir de la zone de du
Dombas donc on sait pas grand chose ce
qui est certain c'est que d'après ce que
disent des Ukrainiens là le flot de de
civil sortant de Mario Paul et remontant
dans zone tenue par les ukrainiens et
beaucoup plus faible donc pour le reste
il est il est pas facile d'en savoir
beaucoup plus la population civile sont
vraiment prisonnières
c'est à dire qu'elles le sont dans la
mesure elles peuvent pas rejoindre un
axe de sortie
ça c'est le premier point et puis vous
avez des populations qui veulent pas
partir des vieillards qui ont pas
vieillards soit des jeunes qui veulent
se battre soit des vieillards qui ont
pas envie de partir parce que parce que
ils ont pas envie de partir c'est celle
qui prennent les corridors vers
justement les territoires russes et
qu'elles veulent vraiment sortir et ils
choisissent pas forcément d'aller dans
les corridors il peut y avoir quand même
quelques éléments qui soient favorables
russes une ne soyons pas totalement
manichéen sur peut-être je sais pas je
connais pas le pourcentage mais il peut
y avoir un petit pourcentage de Jean de
Mario Paul qui sont pas morts parce que
la population n'est jamais totalement
unanime on l'a jamais rencontré même
même en France et vous le savez mieux
que moi ça c'est corridor humanitaires
j'en ai gignaci
c'est une c'est une technique russe en
fait le corridor humanitaire ça a été
utilisé par les Russes pour vider les
villes des familles des enfants et de
certains combattants on l'a vu à LEP
pour pouvoir les attaquer plus
facilement et donc pouvoir
conséquences humanitaires et en ayant
les mains libres bombardé plus
sévèrement une zone donc c'est le
corridor humanitaire malheureusement
fait partie d'une stratégie militaire
donc il n'y a pas de corridor
humanitaire aujourd'hui véritable comme
il peut y avoir dans certaines guerres
le droit humanitaire est totalement
bafoué alors c'est pas un droit
humanitaire au sens où il y a pas de
convoi montant avec des vivres et puis
dès qu'on voit sortant avec des gens qui
seraient vendent non c'est plutôt un axe
de fuite qui est ouvert comme comme vous
le dites très justement ça permet
ensuite de bombarder plus massivement
car les bombardements sont pas encore
très massifs si la
mariée
quand on regarde par rapport à d'autres
sièges ce type la fréquence qui est
donnée j'entendais la fréquence de d'un
obus par minute c'est rien
par rapport à ce qu'on fait les Russes
pour rentrer à Berlin c'est un million
et demi d'obur en 8 heures avec 36000
canons donc ils peuvent encore augmenter
la cadence alors sans qu'ils arrivent à
cette densité là mais ça veut dire que
le pire est pas encore et pas encore là
s'ils amène toute leur puissance de feu
ils vont raser Mario Paul complètement
quoi
ça veut pas dire avoir complètement
gagné c'est à dire qu'il peut y avoir
les chants de ruines aide les derniers
combattants ils l'ont les Russes le
connaissent bien puisqu'ils ont joué à
Stalingrad ils l'ont joué dans les
abords de Leningrad et ils savent très
bien que dans les ruines on peut arrêter
d'excellentes troupes c'est comme ça
qu'ils auraient été allemand sur ces
deux grandes villes et ça il le maîtrise
ils savent que ils peuvent jouer leur
ville complet les Russes aussi peuvent
jouer gros ils l'ont joué très gros à
Stalingrad ils ont allez une drag ils
ont tenu un siège absolument remarquable
alors que les Allemands voulaient raser
la ville quoi et donc
c'est malheureusement
ils ont dans leur
réflexion historique des exemples
terribles de combats
qui sont assiégés alors ils ont attaque
ils l'ont rasé
fameux qu'on voit humanitaires donc vous
confirmez que ça fait partie des
stratégies de Vladimir Poutine dans la
guerre pour encore bombarder de manière
encore plus intense
malheureusement je suis d'accord moi
j'ai pas d'expérience d'Alep mais j'ai
allé à grenier et j'ai étudié
l'expérience tchétchène et en fait
quand les Russes ont compris que c'était
pas possible de gagner une guerre
classique ils ont commencé à dissuader
la population à faire des exactions il y
avait vous savez même des enfants qui
dansaient leur danse nationale devant
les chars russes et donc c'était pas des
victimes
qui qui arrivait pas par hasard mais
c'était une stratégie délibérée d'après
plusieurs témoignages de journalistes et
actuellement les Russes les officiers
ils disent que les couloirs humanitaires
sont tout à fait
un faisables mais en direction de la
Russie par contre les Ukrainiens pour
une raison X ils veulent les couloirs
vers l'Ukraine et là il tire soi-disant
sur leur propre population donc toujours
dans la logique de la propagande
la Russie indique jamais un seul civil
n'a souffert des actes de l'armée russe
mais c'est seulement les Ukrainiens qui
tirent sur sur eux-mêmes donc oui c'est
une
réalité terrible de cette guerre et
excusez moi ça me choque la comparaison
avec Stalingrad que ça soit pas Mario
enfin le côté ukrainien qui est attaqué
mais la Russie qui comparé à ça quand
même dans la deuxième guerre mondiale la
Russie avait plusieurs alliés et là
c'est c'est pas la même situation on a
d'accord oui justement alors c'est ça
qui est intéressant à s'acquérir une
cause c'est que il essayait d'avoir des
alliés il me semble-t-il quand même en
Asie centrale il a pas réussi à avoir de
troupes d'Asie centrale en Biélorussie
d'après ce que je lis c'est même
compliqué de récupérer des soldats
biélorusses
il y avait des actes de sabotage je sais
pas si vous avez vu les Biélorusses ont
détruit les chemins de fer qui devaient
livrer les cargaisons militaires ça
reste d'ailleurs les Biélorusses ne
sont-ils pas coopératifs alors que Lucas
and Co était un allié très très proche
de Poutine
location courte n'est plus légitime en
Biélorussie c'est pour ça que
l'opposante c'est de l'ANA tyrannoscaia
et est accueilli à un niveau très élevé
parce que d'après les analyses sérieuses
c'est elle qui a gagné donc le cash and
Co tout computing ce sont des dictateurs
qui restent au pouvoir depuis plus de 20
ans et la population s'appauvrit donc ce
manque de soutien et il était réel en
tout cas un Biélorussie on a bien vu
avec des manifestations la biélorusses
instauré une sorte de visa de sortie
pour laisser les populations à
l'intérieur du pays donc des volontaires
recruter dans ces conditions c'est
compliqué j'imagine il y a un jeu un
exode massif des Biélorusses vers
l'Union européenne aussi général
Dominique de l'or est-ce qu'il y a une
escalade horizontale inévitable
c'est-à-dire une exportation possible du
conflit en frappant par exemple les
territoires frontaliers non membres de
l'OTAN comme la Suède ou la Géorgie
puisqu'on a vu qu'il y avait une
escalade verticale est-ce qu'il va y
avoir une escalade horizontale alors ma
première réponse serait de dire non non
parce que mais le nom logique et pas un
nom acceptable en terme historique et en
prévision pourquoi parce que on a bien
vu que cette guerre
on n'y croyait pas on n'imaginait pas
que la Russie elle est attaqué l'Ukraine
peut-être des combats dans le dos basse
peut-être aux abords la Crimée mais
personne en tout cas la plupart il y
aura toujours quelqu'un pour se
revendiquer qu'il avait prévu l'attaque
russe mais on n'y pensait pas alors la
première réponse c'est non
la deuxième serait dire qu'il faut
rester très très prudent
car un dérapage n'est pas impossible
notamment
quand on voit la résistance ukrainienne
qui est absolument exceptionnelle
mais quand on voit aussi les factures
fournitures d'armement des
Occidentaux qui sont quand même très
importants
on peut se dire que
le risque existe et donc il est pesé par
les gouvernants européens sans doute le
président américain mais il existe d'un
dérapage
ceci dit les difficultés que sans me
rencontrer l'armée russe me laisserait
penser que
il n'ira pas au-delà de l'Ukraine il a
envoyé des signaux les signaux c'est les
missiles et personiques exactement donc
des missiles vous pouvez nous en dire
juste à quelques mots un détectable
enfin en tout cas beaucoup plus
difficilement
jusqu'à macdis c'est-à-dire 4 à 5 fois
plus rapidement qu'un avion de chasse
moderne
plus rapide que que les missiles
anti-missiles alors ça peut être
confirmée par les Américains qu'ils
aient utilisés
encore que peut-être que ils peuvent le
faire une manière non-officielle mais en
tout cas il est dispose de ses moyens là
fait partie de ce message voilà c'est un
message c'est un message pour dire on
est capable de c'est pas tellement les
objectifs qu'ils ont frappé qui ont un
intérêt mais pas un intérêt stratégique
mais par contre le message lui a du sens
mais je n'ai très sincèrement je
souhaite ne pas le voir j'en ai gagné la
diplomatie est-ce qu'elle a encore une
place justement là on parle de la
possibilité d'un conflit une escalade
horizontale
en fait la diplomatie la vraie
négociation commencera à partir du
moment où Poutine estimera à tort ou à
raison qu'il a suffisamment de gage pour
pouvoir obtenir le maximum sur la table
et à partir du moment où c'est Lenski
comme pour l'instant et les Ukrainiens
sont en train d'augmenter leurs mains en
fait chaque jour qui passe augmente la
capacité de négociation des
Ukrainiens c'est très clair la
mobilisation tout un peuple la crainte
d'avoir à se battre maison par maison
dans toutes les villes je pense que
Poutine manifestement comme vous l'avez
dit tout à l'heure à renoncer à certains
de ces objectifs c'est très clair
pardon Vladimir Poutine a renoncé
probablement rentrer dans le dessin plus
facilement ou à carcov par exemple ville
considéré comme ruisso fun et là il
n'arrive pas à y rentrer donc il y a un
moment il va dire bon ça y est j'en ai
assez pas besace si je puis dire
pardonnez-moi ces termes un peu vulgaire
alors qu'il y a 3 millions et demi de
réfugiés et des morts etc et Zelenski
dira j'ai fait la preuve de la force de
ma nation parce qu'il y a la nation
derrière elle et à ce moment-là on va
commencer une vraie négociation mais ce
point n'est pas arrivé nous sommes
encore dans une phase de monter en
tension et de monter d'escalade encore
c'est il avait renoncé me semble-t-il
justement à rentrer dans l'OTAN c'était
un peu ça ce qu'il disait la semaine
dernière il a dit qu'il était prêt à
discuter et que de toute façon il était
obligé de constater que le temps n'était
pas prêt à le à le recevoir mais c'est
une ouverture est-ce que c'était une
façon pour lui de montrer qu'il y avait
une ouverture vers une discussion
possible
peut-être que à un moment Poutine avait
rêvé prendre l'ensemble de l'Ukraine
peut-être qu'il avait même rêvé de
prendre la rive gauche du niep et il
voit que rien de cela n'est possible
donc il lui reste quand même sa vieille
revendication depuis 20 ans c'est-à-dire
la neutralisation l'Ukraine et donc ces
propos de zélinski plus cette vieille
revendication russe il y a la mort d'un
début de début de négociation comment
les Ukrainiens pourraient-ils accepter
une neutralisation de l'Ukraine comment
les Ukrainiens mais ils l'ont accepté
par exemple entre 2010 et 2013 ils
avaient un président qui était
d'ailleurs contrairement à ce qu'on dit
un patriote ukrainien mais qui qui était
prorus et qui avait négocié une loi
constitutionnelle déclarant la
neutralité de l'Ukraine donc c'était un
président parfaitement légitimement élu
avec une élection tamponnée par l'OSCE
et par l'ONU et par la communauté
internationale donc en fait six Hélène
ski qui est un président légitimement
élu avec 73% des voix décident de son
peuple la neutralité il aura une
certaine légitimité pour le faire il
utilise justement il tire les leçons de
cette paix précédente qui finalement
n'était pas vraiment une général de mine
Delors
il faut sortir de cette guerre donc
c'est tout le travail des diplomates et
puis de façon à trouver les conditions
politiques diplomatiques et militaires
permettant de revenir à une forme
d'équilibre est-ce qu'on est arrivé à au
point de bascule je suis d'accord avec
vous on n'y est pas encore parce que on
ne sait pas si russes sont soumis sur la
table au plan militaire seul c'est lui
seul qu'il sait en fait jusqu'au il peut
aller au plan militaire et jusqu'où il
veut aller et à un moment il acceptera à
mon avis la discussion parce que il
pourra plus en mettre beaucoup sur la
table et si les Ukrainiens tiennent
encore s'ils sont pas parce que
manifestement les manœuvres Russes de
chaudron vont s'arrêter parce que il y a
la Raspoutine ça qui démarre à la fin de
la semaine donc
ça va figer un peu les opérations dans
les campagnes il restera les combats
dans les villes et qu'on va dans les
villes comme comme on a parlé tout à
l'heure il n'y a pas suffisamment la
force pour réduire il va peut-être
réduire Mario Paul à la fin de la
semaine mais il aura il aura pas conquis
carcope au dessin et encore moins
kievenko est-ce que vous voyez une place
pour la diplomatie vous
en premièrement je pense que les lait
d'or occidentaux quand elle parle avec
Poutine et ils doivent quand même le lui
dire clairement la raison est sur cette
fausse idée parce qu'en fait l'Ukraine
était déjà une autre il y avait la
flotte russe stationnaire imprimée on
pouvait voyager en Ukraine et en Crimée
bien sûr avec une pièce d'identité
nationale et même pas le passeport qui
est nécessaire pour voyager à l'étranger
il y avait des liens d'amitié en Ukraine
c'était possible de faire les études
supérieures en langue russe à donuts
c'était possible et il a quand même
commencé le premier cet escalade dans
ces discours dernièrement après le début
de la guerre il y a beaucoup de choses
inquiétantes par exemple il dit que il y
a une loi à Ukraine qui qui est contre
les Russes c'est la loi des protections
des peuples autochtones pour n'importe
quelle analyse c'est clair que c'est
pour la protection des Tatars de Crimée
à l'instar des lois qui protège des
Amérindiens au Canada ou bien aux
Etats-Unis mais donc il a vraiment
quelques fausses idées et que le drapeau
ukrainien c'est le drapeau nazi et je me
demande est-ce qu'il y avait un leader
occidental qui essayait de ne pas
seulement dire oui par politesse mais
essayez de faire le contre argument
après je comprends que voilà c'est
Vladimir Poutine malheureusement avec la
Russie
ici un pays surtout un pays positif
montre une faiblesse soit disant après
Poutine encore plus et plus c'est aussi
ça qu'il faut tenir en compte maintenant
les populations russophone elle a été
tellement bombardée à captive Mario Paul
qu'elle est devenue encore plus un tirus
que la population de l'Ukraine
occidentale et comment Vladimir Poutine
va gérer tout ça
c'est une question compliquée
le président russe en tout cas Vladimir
Poutine utilise des réfugiés comme une
arme c'est ce qui est en train de
d'affirmer Joseph Borel donc le chef de
la diplomatie européenne générale de
mythe Delors c'est vrai qu'on parle donc
là en avoir plus jusqu'à 10 millions des
réfugiés Ukrainiens il y en a déjà plus
de 3 millions qui ont quitté l'Ukraine
est-ce qu'effectivement Vladimir Poutine
crée une sorte de crise des réfugiés et
bien volontairement ça serait en fait
comme dit Joseph Borel une autre arme
pour Vladimir Poutine
faut être un peu plus clair je pense
c'est à dire que les réfugiés se sont
ceux qui sont sortis l'Ukraine 3
millions et demi peut-être et puis 7
millions de déplacés des dépassés qui
qui migrent vers l'ouest vers le
nord-ouest dans des zones plus sûres où
là effectivement c'est c'est un flot de
population considérable qui va peut-être
encore augmenter et qui vide toute la
partie orientale d'une grande partie de
sa population
ce qui va d'ailleurs lui rendre service
parce que justement ils sont manipulés
c'est une manipulation
que nous avons été bien payés pour le
savoir aussi des réfugiés en France
pendant les différents conflits on
touchait le Nord particulier le nord et
l'est de la France et donc c'est ces
populations partent en direction d'une
zone plus sûr on peut comprendre les les
parents les avec leurs enfants Les
grands-parents etc donc si vous voulez
c'est du classique dans la guerre les
déplacés c'est du classique maintenant
avec ce n'est pas particuliers à
Vladimir Poutine ça serait pas une
utilisation justement de ces réfugiés ça
fait partie de des multiples armes
utilisées dans les conflits que de
saturer un peu les autres avec nous
l'avons vu pendant la deuxième guerre
mondiale ou c'est colonnes de de
réfugiés qui venaient de l'Est ont
complètement saturé les les réseaux
routiers et empêcher les mouvements de
force pour essayer de s'opposer
au trop allemand donc on voit que c'est
ça fait partie de la manœuvre de la
guerre malheureusement genre de Guignes
si un mot peut-être justement toujours
sur les diplomatie manifestement il y
aurait peut-être une carte israélienne
est-ce que Israël pour être
effectivement une sorte de médiateur
écoutez oui alors mais ce qu'on voit
comme on est encore une fois dans une
phase tout à fait préliminaire donc on
voit que rien n'est refusé il y a eu
cette réunion Antalya avec les Turcs
dernière et les Turcs ont identifié 6
points enfin qui sont satomes toujours
autour des mêmes sujets et puis
maintenant il y a les les Israéliens
effectivement il y a une communauté
d'origine russe importante en Israël les
relations d'Israël sont bonnes à la fois
avec l'Ukraine et avec la responsabilité
juive dans les deux pays
il y en a moins en Ukraine parce que il
y en a beaucoup qui ont été tués dans
les circonstances qu'on sait avec la
Shoah il y a un moment il y avait des
contacts à la Biélorussie à la biélorus
il y a eu des contacts à la frontière
polonaise alors c'était plus des
contacts humanitaires couloir etc et
Ukraine donc à la frontière biélorus et
à la frontière polonaise puis à nouveau
biélorus donc en fait pour l'instant on
est dans une phase préliminaire ou tout
est tout est envisageable on met sur la
table ce qu'on veut on utilise tous les
canaux mais manifestement c'est pas
cristallisé encore la négociation en est
encore une fois une phase tout à fait
préliminaire et la relation avec
justement Emmanuel Macron entre Emmanuel
Macron et Vladimir merci
un rôle parce que j'étais très frappé
par un article un interview du ministre
étrangère lavre qui disait qu'il
reconnaissait que en gros Macron faisait
des efforts et que il n'était pas c'est
le terme qu'il a utilisé couché devant
les États-Unis comme les autres pays
européens donc c'est intéressant ça veut
dire que la France n'est pas exclu du
jeu
qui sera assez logique des étapes
peut-être qui n'en livraient des armes
ni aux uns ni aux autres je pense que ça
peut être aussi un critère de choix pour
trouver des nations c'est important qui
qui sont si je veux dire à l'équilibre
entre les deux parties car
choisir en négociateur des Occidentaux
alors que nous sommes clairement
exprimés en faveur de l'Ukraine ça me
paraît vous éliminer la carte française
du coup
des ravages sur les troupes russes donc
peut-être israélienne du coup
livre aussi pas mal mais peut-être O2
aussi disons que c'est moins connu
livre aussi il livre aussi en Ukraine et
en Russie
les Syriens sont aussi dans la partie
via pour pour Israël et les Russes donc
évidemment ça compte non mais il y a
peut-être une autre
pas exclure peut-être un jeu des Chinois
la limite j'ai des Chinois on me dit
comme médiateur oui médiateur les
Chinois
on a plus le temps je suis d'accord avec
ça à la politique chinoise est une
grande subtilité il soutiennent sans
soutenir il parle aux uns comme aux
autres il y a eu des déclarations très
favorables ukrainien de la part de
certaines autorités chinoises c'est un
jeu très subtil et comme les Russes
dépendent maintenant de chinois puisque
compte tenu de la situation ils n'ont
pas d'autre choix que ça les Chinois les
tiennent bien et ce sont ceux qui sont
capables d'obtenir quelque chose
merveilleux coup pour eux vis-à-vis des
États-Unis merci beaucoup général
Dominique de leur devoir était avec nous
merci à vous gens de guiniasty merci
beaucoup Anastasia kirilenco vous étiez
avec nous en direct de Londres merci à
vous tous de nous avoir suivi vous
restez avec nous sur France 24
France Info